ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte 8a
und 8b und auch dazu können wir ganz fix
zwei sätze sagen es geht um zwei anträge
aus der fraktion die linke der erste
trägt den titel würde und teilhabe ernst
nehmen sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung
stadt bürgergeld und der zweite titel
existenzminimum sichern
inflationsausgleich bei regelsätzen
garantieren hintergrund ist die aktuell
hohe inflationsrate die wir haben auf
der einen seite und auf der anderen
seite dass der linksfraktion die reform
von hartz 4 wie es jetzt die ampel
koalition angestrebt hat nicht weit
genug geht details dazu werden wir
details dazu werden wir im laufe dieser
debatte hier hören erste rednerin wird
sein katja kipping wie aber kann der
massen sozialsenatorin in berlin werden
könnte da haben sich bislang noch nicht
alle parteien zu geäußert zu dem
koalitionsvertrag der hier verhandelt
worden ist in berlin es läuft der
mitglieder entscheiden noch bis morgen
und dann wissen wir mehr und dann könnte
es sein dass katja kipping den bundestag
verlässt habe ich jetzt erstmal die
beiden anträge zur sozialpolitik
[Musik]
die linke für die überwindung von hartz
4 und das aus gutem grund denn hat vier
bedeutet armut per gesetz
in all den jahren war hier im bundestag
immer ein abwehr muster zu beobachten
die anhänger der hartz4 sanktions logik
versuchten die hart arbeitenden menschen
gegen die erwerbslosen auszuspielen als
ob die verkäuferin auch nur ein cent
mehr in der tasche hat wenn es andere
noch schlechter geht und wir wissen doch
das gegenteil ist der fall niedriges
sozial leisten und das damoklesschwert
der sanktionen hat das lohnniveau nach
unten gedrückt wer es möchte dass die
verkäuferin mehr bekommt muss sich für
höhere löhne einsetzen aber nicht für
niedrigere sozialleistungen
wir lassen hartz 4 hinten
das war das große versprechen der spd
heißt es in den umfragen schlecht gingen
die grünen versprachen im wahlkampf dann
immerhin eine erhöhung um 50 euro und
zwischen steht fest die ampel wird die
sozialleistungen nicht erhöhen hat vier
heißt jetzt bürgergeld aber es ist
weiter armut per gesetz und ich sage
neue begriffe allein füllen keinen
kühlschrank wer hat hier wirklich
überwindende der muss gute arbeit und
eine sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung in
höhe von 1200 euro durchsetzen
und auf jährliche anpassung klett weit
hinter der inflation zurück während die
lebensmittelpreise im november um 4,5
prozent gesteigen sollen die
sozialleistungen nur um 0,7 prozent
steigen 4,5 prozent anstieg bei den
lebensmittelpreisen 0,7 jährliche
anpassung der sozialleistungen dh bei
den arm wird weniger geld zur verfügung
stehen für lebensmittel der kampf gegen
armut
ab fordert empathie für die betroffenen
einen regen austausch mit ihnen aber
erfordert schlichtweg auf geld und
deshalb braucht es einst so trinkt muss
um der fdp kontra zu geben und höhere
steuern auf millionen erbschaften
millioneneinkommen und millionengewinne
durchzusetzen sei ein jammer dass diese
um abfall nicht zu fitness gedanken
und an die adresse von spd und grünen
dass ihr im moment eures erfolges just
das versprechen gegenüber den ärmsten
sofort vergessen habt das wird an euch
hängen bleiben das wird dann durch
hängen bleiben wenn ihr hier nicht nach
steuert
meine damen und herren oft wird ja so
getan als ob armut und platz vier nur
die probleme der anderen seien die
korona krise hat uns jedoch einst sehr
klar vor augen geführt es kann sehr
schnell gehen gerade noch läuft das
geschäft gut und dann ist man auf
unterstützung angewiesen und deshalb
gilt ein sicheres soziales netz sozialer
garantien sind nicht nur für die akut
darauf angewiesenen wichtig sondern sie
prägen das ganze gesellschaftliche klima
kurzum von sozialen garantien
profitieren wir alle und deswegen nur
die linke nicht locker lassen und weiter
dafür streiten vielen dank
der kipping für die linksfraktion
nächste rednerin auf unserer liste
annika klose neu im deutschen bundestag
war juso landesvorsitzende hier in
berlin ist also eine von den knapp 50
spd abgeordneten unter
35 und auch sie hält hier heute ihre
erste rede im parlament
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
sozialdemokratie wurde mit dem ziel
gegründet einen menschen ein leben frei
von armut und ausbeutung zu ermöglichen
dass die zahl der menschen in unserem
land die von armut bedroht sind derzeit
steigt ist für uns inakzeptabel durch
die korona kann gebiet droht sich die
finanzielle situation von menschen mit
geringen einkommen noch weiter zu
verschärfen daher danke ich den kollegen
von der fraktion die linke für ihre
beiden anträge mit denen sie diese
wichtigen themen heute hier auf die
tagesordnung setzen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich kann ihnen aber
versichern
unsere koalition wird mit aller kraft
daran arbeiten für alle menschen in
diesem land ein leben in mit respekt und
würde zu ermöglichen entscheiden der
kanone
der koalitionsvertrag der ampel fraktion
bietet dafür die richtigen bausteine
diese bundesregierung wird das
bürgergeld einführen und endlich hat es
vier überwinden
über diesen längst überfälligen
paradigmenwechsel nun paradigmenwechsel
in unserem gesellschaftlichen umgang mit
armut und arbeitslosigkeit es ist
absolut notwendig dass jeder mensch in
diesem land zu jedem zeitpunkt und in
jeder lebenssituation mit respekt und
würde bat begegnet wird zu oft haben
menschen im hartz iv-bezug den eindruck
gewonnen dass dies nicht der fall ist
und haben sich durch staatliche
maßnahmen schikaniert gefühlt das wollen
und das werden wir ändern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
fraktion die linke ich finde es schade
dass sie diesen wichtigen
paradigmenwechsel jetzt klein reden
obwohl auch sie jahrelang für genau
diese änderungen gekämpft haben das
bürgergeld ist keine veränderung bloß
auf dem papier sondern bedeutet eine
ganz konkrete verbesserung der
lebenssituation für die betroffenen
menschen
wir machen schluss mit dem
misstrauenskultur und werden eine kultur
auf augenhöhe einführen und so neues
vertrauen schaffen denn wir gehen davon
aus dass jeder mensch grundsätzlich
etwas zu dieser gesellschaft beitragen
möchte dabei werden wir sie unterstützen
das
vertrauen heißt auch in den ersten
beiden jahren des bürgerkriegs bezugs
werden vermögen nicht angerechnet und
die größere wohnung wird nicht überprüft
wer arbeitslos wird muss keiner angst
haben direkt die ersparnisse des alters
zu verlieren oder aus dem gewohnten
umfeld verdrängt zu werden im gegenteil
das bürgergeld bietet neue chancen und
unterstützung in einer sich rasant
werden den wandelnden arbeitswelt kann
niemand mehr davon ausgehen ein leben
lang im selben beruf zu arbeiten
meine generation schon gar nicht daher
schaffen wir auch den vermittlungs
vorrang ab das heißt dass man nicht mehr
den nächstbesten freien job annehmen
muss sondern dass weiterqualifizierung
und eine neue ausbildung gleichwertig
unterstützt werden
und ganz besonders freut es mich dass
wir in dieser legislatur den kampf den
kinder- und jugendarmut aktiv an den
werten gerade für kinder aus familien
und bisherigen hartz iv-bezug werden wir
die lebensbedingungen massiv verbessern
wir werden eine kindergrundsicherung
einführen und jugendliche und kinder vor
armut schützen ganz unabhängig vom
einkommen der eltern
ihre kolleginnen kollegen auch zum thema
sanktionen wurde hier gesprochen von den
sanktionen hat vier system sind vor
allem menschen betroffen die schon
länger in einer grundsicherung sich
schon länger an einer grundsicherung
befinden oft liegt da nicht der unwillen
der betroffenen mitzuwirken zugrunde
sondern es liegt an vorhandenen sozialen
und psychischen problemen
wir wollen diese menschen nicht
sanktionieren sondern wir wollen ihnen
helfen
daher setzen wir vor allem auf
aufsuchende sozialarbeit und neue
angebote
und im kommenden jahr werden wir die
mitwirkungspflichten evaluieren und neu
regeln denn unser sozialstaat nicht vom
solidarsystem das bedeutet dass
möglichst alle ihren beitrag leisten so
wie sie es können und unterstützung
sicher ist wenn man sie braucht dafür
steht das neue bürgergeld
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in der
heutigen debatte geht es auch um die
auswirkungen der inflation auf menschen
mit geringen einkommen dafür möchte ich
zunächst festhalten dass die aktuell
hohe inflationsrate ein temporäres
phänomen ist wie meine kollegin chance
kreativ und martin rosemann letzte woche
schon ausführlich dargelegt haben aber
dennoch werden wir natürlich uns für die
menschen mit geringen einkommen
einsetzen und abhilfe schaffen
insbesondere bei den stark steigenden
heizkosten zu beziehen von
grundsicherungsleistungen werden die
kosten für unterkunft übernommen und
damit auch die gestiegenen heizkosten
und für menschen mit geringen einkommen
ohne grundsicherung haben wir uns als
koalition darauf verständigt dass die
gestiegenen heizkosten über eine
klimakomponente im wohngeld ausgeglichen
werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wie
zurück ihm gesagt niemand soll in diesem
land in armut leben mit dem bürgergeld
der kindergrundsicherung 12 euro
mindestlohn und einer tatkräftigen
bundesregierung wird dieses ziel
realität ich freue mich darauf daran
mitzuarbeiten und auf die künftige
zusammenarbeit vielen dank
vielen dank an die kraftlose
als nächster redner in dieser debatte
hält für die cdu/csu-fraktion kritiker
das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen meine beiden vorrednerin und
haben sie sich redlich mühe gegeben den
anschein zu erwecken dass es einen
großen unterschied zwischen der spd und
den linken gibt mir scheint aber die
linke ist über nacht heimlich der
ampelkoalition beigetreten denn was man
da in dem antrag liest findet sie sich
auch im koalitionsvertrag wieder meine
damen und herren die linke forderte die
sanktionen abzuschaffen den wohnkosten
zuschuss zu erhöhen das schonvermögen zu
erhöhen all das hat die ampel auch vor
die ampel ist also beim arbeitslosengeld
2 einer meinung mit den linken wenn aber
es von der linken über rot-grün bis zur
fdp keine unterschiede mehr gibt der
sozialpolitik dann ist ein
christdemokratischer ein christsozialer
gegenentwurf umso wichtiger
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage der
abgeordneten kipping
herr kollege wichtiger wenn sie ihr den
eindruck erwecken dass das was wir als
linke in diesem punkt vorgelegt haben
die sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung von
1200 identisch ist mit dem bürgergeld
der ampel koalition dann würde ich gern
mal ein paar faktoren abfragen erste
frage sozusagen sind sie der meinung
dass wir die gleichen regelungen bei den
sanktionen haben also können sie mit
sicherheit sagen dass die koalition
wirklich eine hundertprozentige
sanktions freiheit will und zweite frage
und das war der zentrale kern zu dem ich
gesprochen habe ist ihm bewusst dass wir
als linke eine mindestsicherung von 1200
euro wollen und finden dass die
regelsätze mindestens auf 658 euro
erhöht werden müssen und wissen sie dass
die beamten keinerlei erhöhung vorsieht
wenn sie wissen wollen was die koalition
vor hat dann muss ich ihnen sagen das
kann ich ihnen als mitglied der cdu csu
fraktion nicht mehr sagen das haben sie
erhoffen sich nicht bekommen aber ich
kann nur eins sagen was zum beispiel das
thema sanktionen angeht dass sie
ampelkoalition viel vorhat bis zur
regelung eines neuen sgb 2 -gesetzes die
sanktionen auszusetzen und das bedeutet
dass wir dann mit dem nächsten jahr weil
ich vermute mal es wird ziemlich lange
dauern bis dieser gesetzentwurf durch
das parlament geht und sagen und dann
und das geht nicht schneller weise
werden schon noch die verwaltung auch
brauchen ja cool damit das auch
funktioniert sie wollen ja die deutschen
nicht ins chaos stürzen dass wir dann
drei jahre lang schon keine sanktionen
mehr in diesem land haben bei dem
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil vor zwei
jahren die sanktionen de facto
ausgesetzt sind und da sage ich nur
nachtigall ick hör dir trapsen ich
glaube nicht dass die ampel koalition
den motor dann die sanktionen wieder
einzuführen sondern sie wird natürlich
versuchen sie so weit wie möglich
abzuschaffen beim koalitionsvertrag sich
davon auch überhaupt nichts gibst und
deshalb glaube ich nicht dass nachher
die unterschiede zwischen ihrer politik
und der ampel so wahnsinnig groß sind
dessen er homöopathische unterschiede
also es ist wichtig für ein gegenentwurf
und diese arbeit die arbeitsmarkt um die
sozialpolitik der union unser
gegenentwurf der erfolg drei einfachen
prinzipien der christlichen soziallehre
es geht uns um die personalität also die
würde des menschen steht im mittelpunkt
zweitens braucht es die subsidiarität
wonach zunächst jeder das tun soll was
er kann und mit seiner hände arbeit den
lebensunterhalt für sich und die seinen
zu verdienen denn die subsidiarität ist
die voraussetzung für das dritte prinzip
die solidarität wonach jeder der auf die
hilfe der gemeinschaft angewiesen ist
sie auch erhält wenn ich diese
prinzipien an die sozialpolitik der
linken und der ampelanlage dann
scheitern sie kläglich ihre
sozialpolitik erschöpft sich nämlich
darin arbeitslosen menschen mehr geld zu
geben es bequemer im system zu machen
aber würde ist für uns mehr als nur geld
würde und teilhabe bedeutet dass wir
arbeitslosen wieder eine echte chance
geben auf den eigenen beinen im leben zu
stehen uns geht es nicht darum dass es
im jobcenter mucke liga zugeht sondern
dass man da nicht mehr hin muss frau
kipping das ist der unterschied und
apropos jobs denn da es mich wirklich
ärgert muss ich auch leider meine
vorrednerin mit mithaftung nehmen sie
stellen sich gerne hierhin und danken
den mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in
den jobcentern für ihre arbeit und
gleichzeitig bringen sie es fertig auch
wieder heute in ihrem antrag von druck
und repressalien in den jobcentern zu
berichten damit verunglimpfung sie die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter ich
sage hören sie auf damit vor kipping wir
als union sind stolz auf dich
sozialverwaltung unseres landes
und auch das prinzip der solidarität
vorkommt bei ihnen zur einbahnstraße
wenn wir in den letzten jahren zum
arbeitslosengeld debattiert haben haben
wir nur noch über sanktionen gesprochen
dabei betreffen sie bis heute nur einen
bruchteil der menschen
aber wer die hilfe der gemeinschaft in
anspruch nimmt hat auch die
verantwortung schnell aus dieser hilfe
wieder herauszukommen denn am ende
müssen diese leistungen auch durch
steuern bezahlt werden übrigens und
gerade auch von menschen die wenig geld
verdienen sanktionen treffen die
sanktionen treffen die die sich dieser
solidarität verweigern
sie bleiben aus unserer sicht aber
notwendig selbst der chef der
bundesagentur für arbeit detlef scheele
mitglied der spd sagt dass die
sanktionen ein mittel sind um mit diesen
menschen in kontakt zu bleiben hören sie
auf ihn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der ampel meine damen und herren um
es klipp und klar zu sagen eine politik
die nur noch fördert und nichts mehr
fordert wahrnehmen unsere politik ist es
nicht und wird es nicht werden die
erfolge der letzten 16 jahre kann man am
arbeitsmarkt sehen wir haben die
arbeitslosenquote mehr als halbiert
unser gegenentwurf steht würde
eigenverantwortung und hilfe der
gemeinschaft gehören für uns untrennbar
zusammen dankeschön
kein whitacre für die unionsfraktionen
in einer debatte im deutschen bundestag
über zwei zu zwei anträgen der
linksfraktion wo es um das thema
bürgergeld beziehungsweise
mindestsicherung und auch
inflationsausgleich geht und wir haben
wieder einen neuen im parlament nämlich
andreas andreades einer der wenigen die
die seite gewechselt haben wie er
ungewohnt ist oder der wechsel zumindest
nämlich vom pressesprecher unter anderem
im bundesfamilienministerium in die
politik in den bundestag in die fraktion
von bündnis 90 grünen dreher soundtrack
direkt zu anfang man kann vortrefflich
streiten über die unterschiede von der
fdp über die grünen der spd linkspartei
kann man alles tun aber dass sie die
allererste rede die sich hier zu diesem
thema halten nur dazu nutzen stolz zu
berichten dass sie die aller unsozialste
sind das zeigt nur eins ist es gut dass
sie nicht mehr teil dieser
bundesregierung
für menschen in der grundsicherung
wird auch dieser winter wieder ein
besonders harter und das liegt nicht nur
an der inflation die hier genannt wurde
die korona krise die trifft die ärmsten
menschen in diesem land am
allerhärtesten gerade vor einigen
minuten ist ein bericht des
paritätischen veröffentlicht worden der
genau das einmal mehr bestätigt und wenn
dann noch dazu kommt dass die masken
teuer sind dass jedes schulessen das zu
hause eingenommen wird weil in der
schule wieder quarantäne angesagt war
das steht alles auf das geld bei
denjenigen die ohnehin am allerwenigsten
haben und deswegen ist es völlig klar
dass wir an der stelle lösungen vorlegen
müssen und ich sage ihnen eins genau das
tun wir
liebe
katja kipping vielleicht machen wir es
mal ganz konkret an janne an der spiegel
unsere bundesfamilienministerin die hat
am tag der amtseinführung das war eine
der ersten handlungen sofort einen
sofort zuschlag für kinder aus armen
familien angekündigt 2,7 millionen junge
menschen werden genau davon profitieren
das ist was was wir jetzt direkt
umsetzen und zwar mit dem
bundessozialminister und noch eine sache
die mir noch viel besser gefällt daran
gemeinsam in der gesamten ampel dir im
deutschen bundestag
besonders besonders akut ist die lage
bei den steigenden energiekosten bei den
heizkosten und auch da müssen wir
reagieren selbstverständlich deswegen
erst es wichtig dass die jobcenter die
nachzahlungen unbürokratisch erstattet
und zweitens wir lassen auch die
menschen die wohngeld beziehen nicht aus
dem blick schauen sie mal auf seite 91
des koalitionsvertrages wir werden
kurzfristig einen einmalig erhöhten
heizkostenzuschuss zahlen das ist das
was da steht und auch das werden wir
jetzt angehen und jetzt ist winter
kurzfristig heißt selbstverständlich das
muss schnell kommen und das werden wir
jetzt in der ampelkoalition ebenso
angehen
die aktiv maßnahmen die ich genannt habe
sind alles wichtige schritte aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist doch genauso klar
dass diese ersten schritte nur ein
erster punkt sein können um das system
hartz 4 ganz grundsätzlich zu überwinden
die ampel koalition plant nichts
geringeres als die größte
sozialpolitische reform seit der agenda
2010 ja wir werden hartz4 überwinden das
ist das ziel und ein völlig neues auch
in der substanz völlig neues bürgergeld
vorlegen daran arbeiten wir und nichts
weniger ist der anspruch dieser
koalition was heißt das konkret
was heißt das konkret wir wollen einen
sozialstaat auf augenhöhe sanktionen
unter das existenzminimum
sind absolut inakzeptabel und deswegen
und deswegen starten wir genau auf
diesem weg wir werden ein moratorium in
kraft setzen und bis ende 2022 wird es
ein völlig neues gesetz geben und
glauben sie mir wir treten in diesem
prozess der jetzt ansteht dafür ein dass
wir dann auch eine dauerhaft gute lösung
finden an der stelle
zweiter punkt
zweiter punkt der mir wichtig ist ich
sehe das in meinem wahlkreis hier in
berlin neukölln immer wieder es gibt so
viele menschen die gehen erst gar nicht
in die grundsicherung weil sie angst
haben sie haben schlicht und ergreifend
angst ihre wohnung zu verlieren das ist
das was passiert und auch damit machen
wir jetzt schluss in zukunft wird es so
sein dass in den ersten zwei jahren die
tatsächlichen kosten der unterkunft
übernommen werden ohne wenn und arbeit
ist ein riesengroßer schritt den kann
man gar nicht hoch genug einstufen
gerade vor dem hintergrund dass wir
damit verdeckt der armut angehen
und ein weiterer punkt ist wichtig wie
oft haben wir den satz gehört arbeit
muss sich lohnen aus den ganz
verschiedenen ecken jetzt gehen wir das
tatsächlich konkret an wir regeln die
hinzuverdienstmöglichkeiten völlig neu
schüler innen und studierende zb in der
grundsicherung sind sollen künftig das
was sie verdienen auch behalten können
auch das ein riesiger schritt übrigens
ganz besonders für die jungen menschen
in unserem land und
zum schluss komme ich zu einem punkt der
mir sehr wichtig ist im
koalitionsvertrag steht dass das
bürgergeld und ich zitiere
gesellschaftliche teilhabe ermöglichen
soll und an der stelle mache ich keinen
hehl daraus wir grüne haben sehr genau
berechnet was das bedeutet und wir sind
an der stelle sehr sehr klar die
regelsätze sind zu niedrig die
regelsätze müssen steigen und das werden
wir in der debatte und in der reform die
jetzt ansteht auch genau so in den
mittelpunkt stellen
sie war jedoch schluss kommt die zeit zu
ende ist ein letzter satz die umsetzung
des ganzen die beginnt jetzt wir machen
uns an die arbeit und das machen wir
zusammen mit den wohlfahrtsverbänden das
machen wir zusammen mit den
gewerkschaften und islamischen
initiativen und das wird nicht leicht
aber ich bin mir sicher wir schaffen
einen echten paradigmenwechsel vielen
dank
vielen dank
für die afg fraktion erhält jetzt das
wort auch für ihre erste rede garrett ui
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren verehrte bürger
die fraktion die linke will hartz 4
empfänger angesichts der stark
angestiegene inflation mit einer
aufbesserung ihres regelbedarfs
unterstützen das finden wir gut
gar nicht gut finden wir allerdings dass
sie wesentliche teile der bevölkerung
dabei komplett vergessen hat nämlich
sehr sehr viele rentner und leider auch
sehr viele beschäftigte die mit ihrem
einkommen angesichts der rasant
steigende preise nicht mehr über die
runden kommen denn die inflation in
deutschland explodiert im november
betrug die preissteigerung bereits 5,2
prozent der höchste anstieg seit fast 30
jahren heizung strom kraftstoffe
verteuerten sich sogar um mehr als 20
von geldwertstabilität kann da keine
rede mehr sein und genau diese inflation
trifft sozialhilfeempfänger
geringverdiener und menschen mit
niedriger rente am härtesten die
grassierende teuerung frisst zudem ihre
sperre klagen auf das alles scheint die
ampel regierung nicht zu rühren
unbeirrt von den sorgen der bürger
setzte ihren drastischen verteuerung
kurs fort der grund der bürger soll
erzogen werden er soll weniger heizen
weniger auto fahren weniger fleisch
essen all das wird gezielt verteuert es
verteilt sich aber auch vieles andere
mehr denn energiekosten stecken in
praktisch allen produkten und diese
werden ja zusätzlich mit der co2 steuer
beaufschlagt als wenn nicht schon genug
steuern in den energiekosten steckten
mehr als 50 prozent der stromkosten und
fast 70 prozent der spritkosten sind
steuern und diese wirtschaft schädigen
der co2 steuer soll dann jahr für jahr
weiter erhöht werden wir fordern weg
damit das klima wird sich dadurch
sicherlich nicht umstimmen lassen
wenn die ampel dann auch noch nord
stream zwei blockiert werden die
gaspreise weiter eskalieren und liebe
linke eine sanktionsfreie
mindestsicherung für arbeitsfähige
menschen geht gar nicht sie nennen die
zahlen selbst 7 millionen sozialgeld
empfänger davon gut die hälfte
erwerbsfähig genau dort werden übrigens
auch viele der asylsuchenden nannten die
die ampel ins land holen will schon
heute beziehen zwei millionen ausländer
hartz4 leistung demgegenüber stehen
gerade einmal 15 millionen netto
steuerzahler die nicht nur die hartz4
leistung finanzieren sondern unsere
gesamten staatsausgaben
das ist auf dauer schlicht nicht
finanzierbar schon jetzt bleibt immer
weniger übrig für die eigenen bürger das
armutsrisiko in deutschland ist mit
nahezu 20 prozent eines der höchsten in
westeuropa für den hart arbeiten bürger
steht nur noch die afd ein gehören sagen
wir sorgen wir schauen auf seine nöte
aber auch die regierung muss endlich die
augen aufmachen und erkennen was sie in
diesem land anrichtet
entlasten sie endlich die bürger in
einem ersten schritt fordern wir
erhöhen sie den steuerlichen freibetrag
auf 12.600 euro
das ist der gleiche betrag denn auch der
vdk fordert konkrete tipps
regelmäßig an die inflation an das
entlastet auf effektive weise menschen
mit niedriger rente und geringverdiener
und es bleibt ihnen dann spürbar mehr
netto vom brutto dankeschön
vielen dank als nächster redner in
dieser debatte erhält das wort für die
fdp-fraktion pascal kober und
pascal kober ist sozialpolitischer
sprecher der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir debattieren
hier zwei anträge der linken der eine
beschäftigt sich mit der frage der
steigenden kosten durch die inflation
das ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches
problem das trifft menschen im
sozialleistungsbezug betrifft aber auch
menschen mit geringen einkommen und
letztlich alle in unserer gesellschaft
und deshalb muss da ein gesamtes konzept
durchdacht werden und den anschlag
gebraucht werden darüber werden wir noch
diskutieren
der andere antrag aber den die linke in
den bundestag
eingebracht haben beschäftigt sich auf
dreieinhalb seiten in 17 themenkomplexen
vor allen dingen wird der frage der
ausweitung der sozialleistungen in
unserem sozialstaat im 16 dieser 17
abschnitte stellen sie die frage wie man
sozialleistungen ausweiten kann und nur
in einem einzigen dieser 17 abschnitte
stellen sie sich die frage die menschen
eigentlich den sozialleistungsbezug
verlassen können nur in einem einzigen
dieser 17 abschnitte stellen sich die
frage wie menschen in arbeit kommen
können und allein die gewichtung dieser
themen zeigt den unterschied zwischen
ihnen und uns wir haben in unserem
koalitionsvertrag festgestellt dass wir
die potenziale der menschen in den
mittelpunkt stellen wollen und das ist
der fundamentale unterschiede
aber sie glauben eben nicht an die
potenziale der mensch sie glaube nicht
an die kräfte der menschen sie glauben
nicht an der man die möglichkeiten der
menschen sie glaube nicht an den
selbstbestimmung und
selbstbehauptungswillen der menschen sie
glaube nicht an die chancen und deshalb
kommen sie ganz natürlicher weise zu der
gewichtung wie sie sich in ihrem antrag
zeigt das ist ein ganz ganz großer
unterschied zwischen uns und ihnen denn
wir wollen die menschen im bürgergeld
bezug wendet es dann das bürgergeld sein
wird eben nicht aufgeben wir wollen
ihnen den einstieg oder den
wiedereinstieg in den arbeitsmarkt in
die selbstbestimmtheit ermöglichen und
diesen unterschied in möchte ich hier
ganz deutlich herausstellen und betonen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und schaut man genauer hin in ihren
antrag schaut man dann in diesen einen
abschnitt mit dem sie sich in der frage
mit dem sie die frage aufwerfen die
menschen in arbeit kommen können dann
sind ihnen drei forderungen eingefallen
die eine das ist nämlich die abschaffung
des vermittlungs vorrang den haben sie
bei uns abgeschrieben da stehen auch in
unserem koalitionsvertrag die zweite
nämlich die einführung eines
weiterbildungs geldes auch das findet
sich bei uns im koalitionsvertrag
also schauen wir auf ihre dritte
forderung da sagen sie dass sie einen
rechtsanspruch auf vorrangig
abschlussbezogene aus und weiterbildung
wollen auch wir sagen wir unsere
koalitionsvertrag dass die
berufsqualifizierende ausbildung stärker
in den mittelpunkt der arbeitsförderung
gerichtet und ausgerichtet sein muss
auch das sagen wir nur an der stelle
zeigt sich einmal mehr wie weit sie
eigentlich von der lebenssituation der
menschen entfernt sind weil das kann ja
nur für viele der zweite schritt sein
für viele ist der erste schritt dass man
zunächst einmal die grundkompetenzen
fördert denn es macht keinen sinn in
eine berufsqualifizierende ausbildung zu
gehen wenn man sich am ende
wahrscheinlich gar nicht schafft weil
man die voraussetzungen dafür nicht
mitbringt und diesen realistischen blick
auf die menschen in unserem sozialstaat
muss man haben sonst geht sozialpolitik
am thema vorbei das ist leider bei ihnen
der fall
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
linken es ist eben kein zufall dass sie
ihren antrag so ausgerichtet haben es
ist kein zufall dass sie
leistungsausweitungen in den mittelpunkt
stellen weil für sie die unabhängigkeit
der gedanke der unabhängigkeit vom
sozialstaat für sie kein wert an sich
ist und das unterscheidet sie von uns
und ihnen und das riesen unterschied da
haben wir auch weiter betonen wir werden
ihnen zeigen wie man sozialpolitik macht
damit menschen in die unabhängigkeit des
sozialstaates kommen das ist nämlich
etwas was mit respekt zu tun hat und
dafür kämpft diese ampelkoalition vielen
dank liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
pascal kober sozialpolitischer sprecher
der fdp fraktion war der drittletzte
redner in dieser debatte über zwei
anträge aus der linksfraktion zur
sozialpolitik
insbesondere zur sanktionsfreie
mindestsicherung und zu einem
inflationsausgleich und dazu spricht
jetzt auch peter aumer aus der
unionsfraktion
kolleginnen liebe kollegen
ich darf auf den antrag existenzminimum
sichern inflationsausgleich bei
regelsätzen garantieren eingehen von
inflation meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren sind
grundsicherungsempfänger betroffen ja
aber auch rentnerinnen und rentner
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer und
dass meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ist ein problem unseres landes
unserer gesellschaft und der antrag der
linken zeigt wie eindimensional sie
denken meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren und wenn man sich die rednerinnen
und redner eines teils der ampel
anschaut dann ist es genauso und ich
glaub es zeit auch ihre haltung das
zeigt auch ihre haltung sehr geehrte es
zeigt dass die verbindung von wirtschaft
und sozialpolitik zunehmend in umbruch
gerät in unserem land und aus sicht
unserer partei meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren muss doch zusammen gesehen
werden für uns ist das prinzip der
sozialen marktwirtschaft sehr geehrte
jacobi sie haben es versucht anzudeuten
dass wesentliche unserer entscheidungen
und wenn man ihre rede vergleicht mit
dem reden ihre beiden koalitionspartner
dann ist das selbstverständnis nicht von
wirklich ersten anblick gegeben also ich
bin gespannt wie dann dieses bürgergeld
tatsächlich ausschaut der bundeskanzler
der gestern den rahmen in seiner in
seiner regierungserklärung gesetzt und
ich bin gespannt der coole wie wir dann
darüber streiten und wie man das
liberale bürgergeld mit den ansätzen von
rot und grün zusammen bringt diese
auseinandersetzung ist es wert und ich
glaube wir müssen in unserem land ganz
aktuell schauen dass wir das thema
inflation für alle auch im blick haben
preisstabilität ist thema vor allem der
ezb das ist mir auch klar aber auch
politisch verantwortliche müssen bei
ihren entscheidungen auch ökonomische
vernunft walten lassen ich habe gestern
artikel von hans werner sinn gelesen der
die ampelkoalition als inflationstreiber
beschreibt und da sollte uns allen auch
zu denken geben vor allem auch dem neuen
bundesfinanzminister den zusätzlichen
schulden machen ist auch nicht unbedingt
der richtige weg um inflation
einzudämmen und das meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ist denke ich ein ganz
wesentlicher punkt über den wir uns in
den nächsten wochen und monaten auch
gedanken machen müssen ziel kann es
nicht sein sehr geehrte frau üblichen
sozial garantien verlangen zu verlangen
wie sieht es in ihrer rede gemacht haben
ich habe mir mal geschaut wie der
bundesrat entschieden hat als es um die
erhöhung der regelsätze gibt und ich
habe mir sehr genau angeschaut wie ihr
ministerpräsident der linken abgestimmt
hat wie das bundesland thüringen
abgestimmt hat es hat zugestimmt
bei der erhöhung der regelsätze ja das
ist das ist nicht irgendetwas sondern
ich glaube politik muss stringent sein
und politik muss auch ehrlich sein und
ich denke dass das ist kein anderes
argument es ist ehrlichkeit ja also das
krad fraktionsvorsitzender ist einfach
zu und ich glaube wir müssen schauen
dass wir dort ansetzen wo die probleme
sind wir müssen schauen dass wir die der
preistreiber nach unten bekommen wir
müssen die energie preise senken unser
vorschlag wird sehr schnell gehen eeg
umlage eeg umlage abschaffen arbeit muss
sich lohnen das grundprinzip der
sozialen marktwirtschaft und ich glaube
daran müssen wir arbeiten
da sind die kollegen der fdp in der
ampel gefordert und ich bin gespannt wie
wir das hinbekommen dass das für unser
land auch gut funktioniert wir sind
verlässlicher partner
wir haben die menschen im blick wir
haben aber unser land in gänze im blick
die breite die vielfalt der menschen die
unternehmer die arbeitnehmer und auch
die grundsicherungsempfänger und wenn
man in dieser breite diskutieren dann
sind wir auf dem richtigen weg
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege augen
[Applaus]
als nächstes erhält das wort auch für
seine erste rede im deutschen bundestag
ist mit aline
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren an erster
stelle muss ich mich aber bei der
fraktion die linke erst dafür bedanken
für diesen antrag weil sie geben uns
einfach nochmal die chance diesen
großartigen koalitionsvertrag noch mal
vorstellen zu dürfen nämlich unseren
bürgergeld also viel vielen dank und
und möglicherweise haben sie den auch
gar nicht vorgelesen aber ich komme ja
noch gleich dazu
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
das liegt vielleicht auch daran weil sie
eine sache eine wichtige sache verkennen
bei unserem bürgergeld geht es nicht nur
darum dass wir eine sozialrechtliche
reform voranbringen indem er die
arbeitslosenversicherung verändern
sondern es handelt sich hierbei um ein
neues gesellschaft stärken des und
teilhabe orientiertes konzept meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
was wir was wir aber mit dem bürgergeld
erreichen wollen entspricht den
ansprüchen einer modernen
leistungssystem matic die jeder und
jedem gerecht werden soll meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren insbesondere
von der linksfraktion habe ja schon
vorhin gesagt hätten sie sich unser
koalitionsvertrag ordentlich
durchgelesen hätten sie sich auch ein
paar dinge in ihrem antrag auch ersparen
können aber ich will ihnen ja geschwind
mal erzählen worum es geht
erstens in den ersten beiden jahren der
leistungs berechtigung wird es keine
anrechnung des vermögens geben und wir
werden die angemessenheit der wohnung
anerkennen und das was sie im übrigen
auch fordern deshalb weiß ich gar nicht
warum sie den antrag wieder unverändert
so eingereicht haben meine damen und
herren aber warum ist das denn so
wichtig wir werden mit unserem
wahlversprechen gerecht werden all jenen
respektvoll gegenüber zu treten die
aufgrund der unabwägbarkeiten des lebens
ihren arbeitsplatz verloren haben diese
menschen haben ja teilweise jahrelang
gearbeitet und sollen daher nicht den
duktus zu spüren bekommt dass der staat
jetzt bei dieser schwierigen lebenslage
ihnen alles wieder wegnehmen wird und
das zeugt an respekt was wir gegenüber
den mitbürgern und mitbürger in diesem
land auch zeigen möchten
zweitens wir gehen aber auch
grundsätzlich an die definition der
angemessenheit grenzen ran und sie
werden mir beipflichten dass das in den
letzten jahren hier sehr sehr schwierig
war dass insbesondere mit der union zu
machen jetzt beglückwünschen sie uns
doch dass wir da auch rangehen wollen
und unterstützen sie uns doch auch in
dieser sache
aber das wesentliche aber das
wesentliche kommt ja noch wenn ich wenn
ich so ihren antrag lese zur abschaffung
von hartz iv habe ich manchmal das
gefühl schon dass sie von veralteten
sozialstaats modellen ausgehen wir legen
aber ein konzept zur verfügung das im
übrigen auch unabhängig der
sozialrechtlichen bewertung meiner
meinung auch sozialpädagogisch sehr viel
helfen wird sondern wir stellen im
rahmenbedingungen zur verfügung die
einen größeren personenkreis
einschließen wird und damit wären wir
auch die arbeitsmarktpolitik positiv
beeinflussen während ihr antrag sich
hauptsächlich mit geldleistungen
beschäftigt werden wir im gegensatz zu
ihnen die lebensziele und die wünsche
der menschen in den vordergrund stellen
meine sehr geehrten
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wie
wie schon bereits erläutert worden ist
wir machen das durch ein potenzial
orientierten ansatz wir versprechen
beratung auf augenhöhe und werden vor
allen dingen wieder das vertrauen in die
institutionen wieder herstellen was aber
viel wichtiger in diesem zusammenhang
auch ist ist dass wir ein
kompetenzfeststellungsverfahren
einführen was nicht nur die hard skills
in den vordergrund bringen wird sondern
auch die softskills weil wir den
menschen sehen seine förderung sehen und
danach erst fordern werden
wir werden wir werden in diesem
zusammenhang auch die
eingliederungsvereinbarungen abschaffen
und durch eine teilhabe vereinbarung
ersetzen und ich möchte ihnen noch etwas
wichtiges mitteilen
wir werden ein begleitet begleitung des
coaching und aufsuchende hilfen durch
sozialarbeit zur verfügung stellen das
ist deshalb so wichtig weil wir jetzt
einen schritt weiter gehen müssen um die
lebenswelten der menschen zu verstehen
und die persönliche lage der menschen zu
verstehen und nicht nur vom schreibtisch
aus die ab durch aktenlage bewerten
sondern wir gehen vor ort und
unterstützen die menschen da wo sie ihre
benötigen das ist der vorteil und das
ist auch das neue waffe in unserem
bürgergeld auch beabsichtigen daher
zeigt ihr antrag dass sie nicht
verstanden haben dass es nicht nur um
geld gehen kann sondern dass es um die
individuellen bedürfnisse der menschen
geht und darauf muss man sich einlassen
kommen sie bitte zum schluss hätten sich
um sofort zum schluss ich möchte nur in
diesem zusammenhang sagen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir werden zu
hören weil wir an die mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger glauben und weil wir ihnen
vertrauen und wir werden ein sozialstaat
einen modernen sozialstaat zur verfügung
stellen an denen sich die menschen
messen lassen können vielen dank fürs
zuhören alles gut und eine schöne
weihnachtszeit
diese wünsche haben wir noch relativ
wenig gehört obwohl das ja hier die
mutmaßlich letzte sitzung des
bundestages vor der weihnachts vor den
weihnachtsferien ist das war tag ist ein
mehmet ali aus der spd fraktion jetzt
wird abgestimmt über die beiden anträge
der linksfraktion hatten sie doch bitte
darauf dass sie die masken nicht nur den
mund sondern auch über die nase haben es
ist ja auch ein bisschen
anstrengend immer zu jedem einzelnen hin
gehen zu müssen ich gucke jetzt mal so
ein bisschen auf die rechte seite und
hoffe dass sie das da hinter ihnen der
kollege dass er einfach auf seine nase
nochmal einbezieht in die nacht maske
so so ist es richtig wunderbar
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
vorlage auf drucksache
271 an den ausschuss für arbeit und
soziales
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungs vorschläge das ist nicht
der fall dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen wir kommen zur abstimmung
über den antrag der fraktion die linke
auf drucksache 100 mit dem titel
existenzminimum sichern
inflationsausgleich bei regelsätzen
garantieren wer stimmt für diesen antrag
das ist die linke wer stimmt dagegen
das sind spd bündnis 90/die grünen cdu
csu und fdp während hält sich die afd
damit ist der antrag mit großer mehrheit
abgelehnt so damit haben wir auch
klarheit in dieser angelegenheit einen
antrag abgelehnt der zur sanktionsfreie
mindestsicherung wird im ausschuss für
arbeit und soziales ein wenig weiter
diskutiert werden